[Musique]
si sa tante je fais un concert classique
au début des vacances
ce camp italien à venise boffo joie si
je peux me libérer
mambé a indiqué mme 9 faut toujours
avoir l'air débordés du coup de ton père
te filer dans les chemins mènent à rome
et venise n'est pas bien loin de chanter
je me suis arrangé pour faire un petit
peu de covoiturage on ne veut pas être
le cas dans la voiture mais vous avez
pas y en a qui s'arrête à lyon mais moi
je serais déjà descendu mâcon savant dur
ça les ponts ça dépend ce parquet de
chaumont passe allez on y va je viens de
rencontrer des gens qui voient ma contre
ils vont déposer ce puissant au sénat
met un petit commentaire sympa sur
internet
parlez-en à vos amis à diarra cisse
attentes je fais un concert classique au
début des vacances carrément c ou en
italie à venise
j'aimerais trop rouillé j'ai eu une bien
meilleure idée
on va y aller tous ensemble à venir tess
carrière avec notre cas
[Musique]
tout semble bienvenue chez les dingues
moteur est en surchauffe à cause de la
caravane passe à la voix rauque sûrs
comme des beignets là un garagiste qui
m'a donné ce truc là il faut mettre le
chauffage à fond et ça fait refroidi au
nôtre
bordeaux tout va bien
[Musique]
bonjour vous promet un combat non ben
ammar a fini
[Musique]
j'étais que penser assure moment précis
ce qu'il ya c'est que j'ai peur c'était
quoi
coût
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
il suffit remonter la rivière jusqu'à la
route et d'arrêter quelqu'un est bien
plus simple est ce que vous auriez un
portable tout ce qu'on veut c'est
rentrer chez nous
[Musique]
juste pour bateaux
il ya une créature qui vit dans ses lois
la légende raconte que quand nos chefs
moeurs leurs esprits reviennent
cette créature à capturer votre femme
[Musique]
mitaines de soi
sk ospina
c'est pareil
[Musique]
me fatigue un bonheur total
à
non
[Musique]
stop
d'accord
[Musique]
mettez le four à 180° et laisser cuire
35 minutes merci car nc bat recettes de
lasagnes mexicaine ses pertes
on n'ose pas imaginer ce que vous vivez
c'est comme si jeff se faisait renverser
par une voiture et mouret de façon
soudaine et violente
ça fait ça ne vous pressez pas pour me
rendre là
[Musique]
bienvenue chez les amis du paradis nous
avons de nouvelles têtes aujourd'hui je
m'appelle je dis que jen j'espère que
vous trouverez pas c'est bizarre je peux
vous prendre dans les bras
ça va pas non d'accord j'ai perdu mon
fiancé il a deux semaines
c'est arrivé très vite que ted est mort
je dors plus j'y arrive pas jen se fait
réveiller toute la nuit si tu as envie
d'appeler on pourra ne pas dormir
ensemble alors
bullard ce céline non c'est mon autre
mari attend à un autre tout va bien là
du coup j'ai ouï kabyle comment je porte
des talons de survêt dit le plus
lentement
quoi tu es vraiment bizarre djoudi
m
ça t'arrive souvent de faire ça chaque
fois que je vois un pare-chocs défoncé
je me dis qu'il a pu percuter quelqu'un
ça doit pas être facile d'être dans sa
grande maison sans steve j'ai une maison
d'hôtes si tu veux on sera tous les
jours
le garçon je vous présente justice ali
baba je pense que le petit oiseau et son
père décédé
peut-être que c'est lui c'est trop
bizarre pour moi que tu sois là non mais
qu'est ce que tu sais même pas qui elle
est c'est peut-être une psychopathe
on vient pour gmail qu'elle voulait vous
un tu dis je dirais que partout djoudi
passe c'est le chaos
[Musique]
viens je tu joues avec moi et avec tous
les autres il ya encore tellement de
choses que tu ignores
chagrin de tous nous rendre maintenant
je vous connais vous êtes quelqu'un de
bien cinglé ou pas
vous avez une criminelle dans votre
maison djoudi est la seule qui a été là
pour moi qui ne me donne pas
l'impression d'être en échec dans tous
les domaines on a une veuve en colère
qui joue les chiens de garde
[ __ ]
qu'est ce que ce thème toi
[Musique]
je voulais te dire que ok génial je
tente un truc mais va t on